so today we're actually gonna be
building a set piece for one of our
other producers who's working in a web
series you know I'm as the host of
awesome comics and top five and he's
everybody's favorite Zack Snyder
impersonator
Walter benezia so Walter's been working
on this web series for a while now so
Walter needs a set piece built for one
of the scenes in his web series and it's
actually like a visiting room in a
prison but the cubicles with like the
telephones and you're talking through
the glass and stuff that so I think I
have an idea of how I can build that
relatively quickly and cheaply so let's
go take a look at some of the materials
and stuff like that that I've set aside
and we'll just start building and see if
it all comes together
all right so this is my idea I'm gonna
use an existing tabletop this folding
table it's about two feet by four feet
and I went and bought some cheap frames
at Michaels
these are 18 by 24s and it was 50% off
so I think the two of them maybe cost me
like 12 bucks so these will be our
windows I'm gonna take the backing out
of them and so we'll have two
side-by-side that'll be our window I've
got some MDF board two foot by two foot
pieces that are going to be our dividing
walls basically for the phone's the
receivers these receivers these I went
to American science and surplus and you
can buy just the phone receiver it's
kind of like a retro thing that they are
promotional kind of thing that they were
doing where you can plug it into your
actual cell phone and stuff hello
alright so this would be the phone but
I'm probably up the painted black they
do make him in black but they didn't
have any when I was there but I think
actually online I could have ordered
some but I prefer to just pick him up
well while I was already at the store so
that's some black spray paint will spray
them up and I've got these little tool
brackets a package of them I got at a
dollar store for a buck and so I think
that'll work
glue to the side to hang up the phone or
whatever it'll be I've got some
different fasteners and stuff like that
but that's about it I think I'm just
gonna use these materials these will be
my partitions these will be my windows
and I'm gonna paint everything gray so
that it kind of has that I guess prison
feel and yeah I'll probably dirty it up
a little bit touch it up make it look a
little bit used but this is going to be
our core base of materials so let's
start building and see what happens
all right so that's about it
a few of things that maybe you didn't
notice the cables I use the cables that
the phones came with we're sort of the
standard coiled cable they don't have
those in prisons usually it's like a
metal flexible cable so that they don't
pull it out I guess and use it as weapon
or something yeah I didn't have anything
like that but I have a lot of extra
speaker wire so I pulled some of that
off cut it into pieces and actually what
I did is to shoot a screw through the
other end of my little bracket here into
the cable to hold it into place so it's
kind of tight in there doc like this I
don't I'm gonna ask Walter if he wants
me to put some kind of a little graffiti
or something like that a little bit and
probably on the visitors side not the
prisoners ahead yeah I wound up taking
this piece of wood here and putting some
notches in it to hold the top part in
place I didn't screw anything down I
don't have anything affixed anything
what's kind of holding the structure
together is this top piece of wood with
the notches and the little side brackets
that I put in but you know it gets the
job done and all was pretty cheap the
boards were about 350 apiece like I said
the frames we're only like six bucks
apiece because they got a 50% off and
the phones were actually about six bucks
apiece so those are a little expensive I
guess once you add them all up but then
it was a pre-existing table scrap piece
of wood for the top bracket it's gonna
be pretty tight I think as far as when
he Walter shoots it so when he's when
they're talked in and stuff
so if you're getting a nice tight shot
like this then it works out pretty good
we'll take all this stuff away will be
the cinderblock and I think once you add
the sound effects and have a prison
guard standing back there and stuff like
that it'll all add to the sense that
this is a real prison visiting room so
hopefully the Walter likes it I guess
we'll find out in a couple of days keep
your fingers crossed
all right so we're here on set this is
the data filming we're here with Walter
Benedict the final shot of your web
series - long long long years well what
do you think man is it gonna work out
this turned out really good man I really
like how this I mean we yeah you know I
had to keep it tight obviously on the
shots but I mean the windows here like
even like the Knicks over here that
naturally kind of came up look really
good and we put something like a little
graffiti whatever on the side and the
phones were bright originally and you're
painting them black yeah these these
turn out really good I mean looks just
like a little mini jail phone place what
does it even call I don't know it's
thing I like in the beginning of my uh
its windows like visiting like prison
things with the phones in the window you
get to talk to the phone booth visiting
jail place yeah that's really good
thanks man yeah that's awesome the
fridge earlier so I already looks good
cool yeah all right thanks so much I
hope that the web series a big success
now I know me too
all right all right guys I hope you
found this somewhat entertaining or
informative and thanks so much for
watching I really appreciate all the
comments keep them comments come in as
far as suggestions for the Halloween
build episode you guys had so many great
suggestions already that even if I
choose just one for the Halloween
episode I'm gonna get around to building
quite a few of your guys suggestions
I'll probably do that episode sometime
in October I'm not exactly sure when yet
but we've got a few other projects
coming up and I've got one or two ideas
that I want to throw in for Halloween so
keep a lookout for those and look me up
on Facebook and James Jim J Roz and yeah
you guys Rock see you next time